Hey look at this I got a mic for bet try
your mic put on your headphones
I got a mic we were testing out the mics
and the guy said to me can you test out
Beth's mic and she wasn't here she was
fixing the air conditioning
oh my god we were testing the mics and I
go
alright I'll test bets Mike and I go up
to and I go hi I'm Beth I don't like
being on the air yesterday I'm down here
getting the equipment together the new
equipment for the show and I just as I'm
walking down I go honey
I believe the air conditioning in our
bedroom is no longer working and I came
down here and the next thing I know she
fixed it so I was like oh I do want to
announce Beth is rebuilding a Corvette
in the garage she's starting a new
career as a handy person she's good by
the way we kind of ripped her arms are
you know why
tell everyone what you're doing I'm
doing the hydro she's on that hydro
rowing machine my arms really
she's so the man of the family
ranged it up today cherries Oh Jeremy
need some cherries yeah during are they
in season I don't know they're good I
washed them I got to wash a whole bunch
of fruit today because of this Cove at
19 that's my new thing I have chores and
two chores
watch your fruit no no I have more than
food and to rumba my bathroom you rule
but your bathroom I know I Roomba is the
I have the mopping room by the robot I
have to put the pad on him and prepare
the solution
sorry you guys got my chores I think you
like your new microphone I mean look at
this setup I know it's beautiful yeah
how much of that did you build Beth
you